hi
i'm elle and welcome to my talk i'll
start with a little bit of about me
um for the last decade i've worked
mostly in academic research in various
areas of neuroscience and one constant
in my work
is that i've always done a lot of
mathematical modeling
and i really love getting to use big
computers so after i finished up my phd
last november from the university of
washington
i was interested in how scientists work
their methods
particularly the methods around managing
increasingly complex workflows
and i joined iterative which is the team
that makes dvc or data version control
as a data scientist so uh dvc data
version control
our flagship tool is a tool that you
might know from some of the ml ops
space it's a way of extending git
version control
um to things like data sets and models
that are ordinarily kind of
large and you wouldn't want to manage
with git so that's kind of our
you know our flagship project um
and today i'm going to talk about some
new work that i've been involved with
over the last few months
on our you know our latest project
so let's start with this figure
that i love it's from a case study from
microsoft
and the authors reported that teams
whether they were working on
speech or search or ads whatever as long
as it involved some aspect of machine
learning they tended to follow a very
similar workflow on software projects
that had some
machine learning aspect to them and
of course there's a lot of folks along
this along this trajectory
they're not all data scientists we've
got
data engineers so people who specialize
in collecting
cleaning and labeling data and then data
scientists who
typically would take that data set
that's you know ready to go
and they would do featurizing trying to
understand the data
better hypothesizing building models
and then we've got folks whose specialty
is the software and the engineering
and creating systems and applications
around
models and then serving them keeping
them stable
all that good stuff and this is an
organization
that is run by adorable baby animals
and that's great that's that's exactly
what we need right now
anyway everything is fine if this
project proceeds
linearly going from data engineer hands
off the data to the data scientist who
hands off
their model to the software engineer but
like of course
this never works um i mean as you can
see the authors of this figure have
have drawn in these little little arrows
suggesting some recursion
and indeed that is that is pretty
standard
so there's a couple ways that this kind
of linear flow breaks down
one is that really really great machine
learning models often take you know
quite a few
iterations and feedback and that
feedback can come in the form of
you know maybe our data set is changing
or something about the application is
changing
or it could be that the system
constraints are you know quite
particular and data scientists have to
work with that so they get feedback from
software engineers
um and then they might have several
iterations
of discussing what the model will look
like in production and feeding that
input back into the data scientist work
also data scientists need to be able to
anticipate the constraints
that software engineers will have so
they really need to be able to you know
to see or understand in some way if the
you know the dependencies of the project
that they're developing
locally will work in production
and everybody on the team needs to know
where the data came from and i'm so
sorry that it looks like my head is
cutting off
the baby animal labels but hopefully
from context you can get it
so there's a lot of back and forth a lot
of circularity
and this can all get quite confusing and
complex and it becomes
a thing to be managed in and of itself
but machine learning is although it's
new to the software engineering stack
we have you know a lot of practices from
software engineering
that are great at dealing with
complexity um and
specifically we can look to the field of
devops for some
inspiration so devops is
putting together developers and
operations
so people developers are people that
want to develop cool features they want
to experiment they want to make things
fast
kind of like a data scientist can try
out a bunch of different models
and then ops people that need to keep
the system stable and running with no
interruption so we can think of that as
more of like our engineering guys and
girls
so devops had a pretty big revolution
you know in the last decade or so and
it's now a mainstay of
you know most major tech companies that
they have a lot of devops practices
um but machine learning uh you know it's
still because it's new we're still
figuring out what is a team that works
on a full staff machine learning project
going to be like um
there's not as many devops principles
and standards that are you know
ingrained in the same way as in software
development
um but we have some we're interested in
seeing how well those ideas can extend
and in particular we're really
interested in this big idea of
continuous
integration and delivery which i will
explain and we're going to abbreviate
this ci cd
so cicd is a practice that establishes
collaboration rules between developers
and operations specialists and it's part
philosophy
and part practice so let's take a look
at that means let's get you know a
little less abstract
the idea is that you have a code base
for your project
and whenever there's a change in your
source code
a build will happen automatically and
then some tests get run on that build
and if the build passes the test then
the modified source code becomes a
candidate to be merged into the main
branch of your project
and if you fail then you can keep
iterating on this
and you might be able to tell from the
way i'm talking that this is often
done with git that we take out a branch
a new branch to try out some new
features and when we push that branch
when we make this pull request
to our central you know our ci server um
then we will be getting the test run and
then
if everything goes well then we can
merge the branch
into the main part of the project and so
we're using a git flow where the main
branch is
presumably what will go to production
and we use branches to experiment
so the idea here is that actions like
git commits and pushes will trigger
feedback
and every round of feedback can produce
a release
candidate because we're always testing
and because we're always preparing to
release something
we're like it's really fast to turn
around something new the idea is to get
out of like
you know having to wait months and
months to test something out because
you know to get it ready to go into
production because
every day you're used to testing so
let's take a look at what's different
when machine learning is part of your
workflow
so a couple things first of all it's not
enough to monitor changes oh sorry
here we go it's not enough to monitor
changes in your code base anymore you
also have to monitor changes in your
data set so
machine learning models are their sort
of code
and their sort of data they are a
function
but they're you know it's they're not
really that defined by their code on a
lot of applications and
particularly in deep learning it seems
like
data is what really drives the result of
what
you know what the model is like so we
have to monitor for changes in our data
set because if the training data changes
that's as good as changing your model
another difference is that instead of
building software
we're not you know we're no longer
compiling we're training
models or anything for training them you
know it's
it's intensive sometimes um you know a
lot of the computers that can run
a standard build for software
development
are just not up to training a deep
learning model or even
a quite large you know linear model um
if you've got to do a really
big matrix decomposition you don't
always want to do that on
the computers you have lying around
sometimes you're going to need some
hardware
or just some special cuda drivers you
know it's not trivial
another difference is that when we run
tests you know
we have these these we're actually
evaluating
the model you know we're going to maybe
the way we evaluate it is not like these
pass
fail kind of things it's like
i just gave it some new data some held
out data and i want to know how my new
model performed and we have to be kind
of detailed
and you know investigative about it
because of
just knowing a single score like okay
did my accuracy
improve on the new model is not really
enough because we may have in fact
lost something like we've we've reduced
precision
you know and perhaps that's really not
okay for our
application and so this kind of
evaluation of did my model get better
actually requires some domain knowledge
both about
what you know how data science works and
about the problem that you're working on
so these are things that you know
does not do not really make sense to
binarize into checks when you
we really want a more conclusive and
detailed report about how the model
performs
so why don't we have this yet a few
reasons
first of all version control can't
always track changes in data sets
so like i had talked about a lot of this
is very get driven it's very git
centric and you know a lot of data sets
are not things that you want to be
keeping
in your github repository um data sets
are frequently
on the you know a bit too large for
traditional version control so we need a
way to deal with that
if they're going to be triggers as well
as code changes
next is that training models isn't like
building software so again
um sometimes our our cpus that we have
around
are just not enough and we need a little
bit of extra power
and evaluating metrics is more
complicated
all right so what's next this is where
we come in
so the philosophy of my organization is
that
we build tools that are going to extend
you know practices from software
engineering to ml
and in specific here we're looking at
how can we extend ci cd practices from
software engineering to ml
and we are tool makers um
so we're kind of going to start here
i'll show you our tool but first
i'll show you kind of a wish list of
these are the issues that we
think are most important to solve first
of all we have to have some kind of more
advanced data management we need to be
able to version data like code
next we need our ci system to be able to
allocate cloud resources to train models
so it has to be very flexible because at
this moment in time
you know there's a lot of different
solutions for orchestrating the compute
resources to do
machine learning or deep learning so we
want to be able to have your ci system
use whatever resources you know like
likely in the cloud but could be on
premise whatever
but you know it needs to be flexible to
use your compute resources
and we want to be able to provide
feedback in the form of not checks
but metric reports and even possibly
data visualization or
interesting samples from a trained model
lots of possibilities here
so i'm going to show you now how we've
been approaching this so far
the work that i'm going to show you is a
collaboration with dimitri pedro dimitri
is the dvc creator and ceo of our
organization
david is a developer who's been working
on this project with us from the
beginning and
me i'm a data scientist
okay so now that we know a little bit
about
what we want i want to tell you how
we're going to do it so
our team we work on dvc dvc
is a way of extending git version
control
to larger things like model files data
sets
big things that you don't want to stick
in to get but that are really critical
for machine learning projects
um so because we're in the git ecosystem
our attention has been caught by
a couple of developments in that world
we have github actions which is a
continuous integration
system that is supported by github so
it's basically uh anytime your github
repository detects a change
they will provision a computer for you
and you can run whatever workflow you
want it is really cool
and there's a neat marketplace of
actions that you can check out
and there's also get lab ci cd um again
my head is cutting this off but get lab
ci
is a wonderful suite it's it's really
i think it's like one of their
specialties it's a beautiful ci system
so both of these
for the purposes that i'm going to talk
to about today
are interchangeable we've developed the
tool that i'm going to show you to work
with both of them
and i'm going to kind of give the
examples and the rest of this talk in
github because of
just because of it's completely free so
it's maybe a little bit easier for
somebody who's totally new to this to
get in but everything i'm going to show
you works fine on both of these and
there is
no difference in what you can do in
these systems as far as my talk is
concerned
okay so here's our project name
continuous machine learning
we have started an open source project
about using continuous integration from
these two systems github actions and get
lab ci and we're planning on expanding
to some other
common providers um with machine
learning
so continuous machine learning here's
our beautiful logo and there's two ways
that you can follow our project one of
them is on the
cml.dev website and we spent a lot of
time developing like
use cases here um okay
oh there we go we spent some time
developing use cases
um you know so all different kind of
projects that are ready to go out of the
box that you can copy and paste to your
own project
and try making them for both github and
gitlab
um and we've got a repo on github that
you can
come in open issues make a pull request
for a new feature
um it's it's pretty active and it's got
tutorials all that
okay so let's revisit this figure
so github actions where does this fit in
um i'm going to highlight it it's this
part
so what github actions does is that it
can automate
training and testing a model and then
return the results to you in your pull
request
by default this workflow so whatever is
your training job can be run on runner
machines provided by github
but you can also use your own machines
too so cml
works with github actions so cml is not
a new
continuous integration system it's kind
of a library and a set of methods that
you can use with either github actions
or gitlab ci
to help adapt those services to work
with machine learning because right now
github actions is really designed mostly
with software development
in mind but we think it's quite flexible
quite powerful
and can offer a lot here too so i'm
going to take us through
how the priorities that we laid out
earlier show up
in cml so first let's talk about
providing feedback in the form of metric
reports
okay so let's say that we have a project
in github and we're going to use github
actions to automate
training and evaluating a model um so
what we do is we create this
special yaml file that's always going to
be in the same file path
you just place it in this github
workflows file
and this is the secret sauce for any
github action no matter how simple or
complicated
you create a yaml file here and you're
going to give it some
you know a couple of arguments in the
yaml format
and give it some instructions to run and
then whatever you say is what
github will do when you when you it
detects a change
so we have our file here we're selecting
some triggers
so for me i'm saying my trigger is going
to be push when the repository detects a
push
then this workflow is going to be run i
am specifying a docker container here so
i'm pulling first uh the operating
system for the runner
and that's for the machine that github
is provisioning for me
a runner managed by them i'm pulling the
docker container for the cml project
you can also use your own docker
container or you can use no docker
container
and so when this happens we're going to
run the following workflow we will
install some requirements
we're going to run a python train dot pi
is my script
and then we're going to uh use some cml
functions with and a little bit of batch
scripting here
um it's it's fairly mundane stuff and
then we're going to use this to write
a markdown file report.markdown
and we're going to use cml to deliver
that markdown
file and i'll show you what that means
essentially
when you make a pull request you get a
report
and it appears as a comment in the pull
request so
here you can see that we've got you know
we made a commit
on this pull request and we printed out
the accuracy of the model that was
trained by pythontrain.pi
and we printed out a picture and the
picture is an ordinary
png file it's not special in any way
and so the value of having this appear
in your pull request
is that now this result from your model
training
is visible to your team and when you
decide if you want to
merge this model into your you know the
main branch of your project
you have this available to you and it's
always linked to the commit
that generated it so
hopefully when you have this you and
your team can have a more informed
discussion
and a conversation about whether or not
this is merge worthy
let's take a closer look at what exactly
is run in the workflow
we have a training script that outputs a
text file of
metrics and a confusion matrix so the
first thing we do is we do some bash
scripting
to take the contents of metrics.text put
them in the markdown report
then we're going to use this publish
function that we we've created here
to take your confusion matrix png host
it somewhere
and put it in the report and then we
deliver the report with cml to your pull
request
okay here's another example where i'm
using dvc
to make a table that compares model
performance metrics from the last
experiment with the master branch of the
project
so dvc you don't have to use cml with
dvc for the record they are totally
distinct
but because of dvc creates tools to do
things like
a diff for model performance across
two different git branches i think it
fits really naturally with cml
and anything else that you're doing with
git flow so if you're doing git flow and
data science
i think dvc is very natural but i'm very
biased here
this is my team so here i'm using dvc
metrics diff to create a table that says
how the metrics on my current branch
compares to what's on the main branch of
the project
and i'm also using dvc plots to plot the
difference in the loss functions
and fyi metrics are dvc plots are just a
wrapper for vega light plots
um so this would appear in your pull
request and here's another example using
tensorboard so we wrote a helper
function
so that when you open the pull request
you'll get a link to your
tensorboard.dev page
where you can track your model training
in real time so if your model is
training on these remote computers
you can still see it training on a
tensorboard
and there's a ton of flexibility here
you can pretty much play anything that
can go
in a github markdown document so like
anything that you could imagine putting
on like the readme of a project
um can go in one of these cml reports
um so you could be making your plots
using whatever visualization library you
prefer it could be seaborn or ggplot
vago whatever and likewise any way of
generating a table too
so this works with every programming
language because of it's very high level
and it's quite agnostic
um so python and r even though i'm only
showing you python examples
it works quite well with r
okay so we've been exploring a couple of
ways to use these reports like in what
situations do they provide the most
value and there's a couple cases that
we've considered
so one as in the example i showed you is
that you can use the report
to tell you about how model training
went on your remote machine so it could
be either to use it with tensorboard to
track model training in real time on a
remote machine that was
you know if your training job was
triggered by the continuous integration
system
um or it could be to simply return um
you know some of this model evaluation
like what does the confusion matrix with
my trained model look like
it could be on your training data or on
your validation data
um i really like transparent
reproducible and detailed test results i
think that you know
even though we're just at the beginning
of what we can put in a report and
thinking about it i think that
the real strength is coming up with
really descriptive and interesting tests
to put here
and one thing to note is that you don't
have to train your model
using the ci system you can just train
it locally
and then check it into ci when you're
ready so only commit the model that you
like the most
and then this could be a test suite so
you can do things that are akin to like
a unit test on your model or your data
set
and only report the results of of that
so you don't
have to be training in the ci system
to get the value of testing
and finally we can also look at
reviewing data and models like code so
if we have ideas about like model
metrics diffs or a data diff
if we are reviewing you know on a pull
request maybe the data set has changed
and you know we want to make a diff to
see how far has it drifted
from where it is on the main branch um
all of these things can be done and
we're still
building and exploring use cases around
it so the idea here is that similar to
how we
you know might open up a pull request
and as a team review code
changes we can also review data and
models in this way
and kind of to build on this we've been
creating a youtube channel
where we've been taking these use cases
and doing them
you know with code that we've made
available um and just live coding them
and making this available to see what
things people respond to
and we've gotten you know some really
nice responses so we've had this for i
think like six or eight weeks now and
we've gotten
you know almost 17 000 views by today
um so people seem to be you know quite
interested in the approach of what can
we use github actions for in automating
my machine learning pipeline
um and so yeah so like i said we're
still
building up you know cool applications
for it
so the other priority that i wanted to
talk about is versioning data like code
and um in fact this is what we have dvc
for
so our other project dvc kind of was a
precursor to cml because it had to be
there
so dvc extends git versioning to data
sets and models and here's a little bit
about how it works it has a get like
syntax
so if i have a repository where i
already have git working
i can do dvc ad on a data file and i can
push that file to remote storage
so i'm doing dvc add is going to
put the file under dvc tracking and dvc
push will push
my data my csv into cloud storage
and on your local machine dvc will
create this
lightweight metadata file so it would
create a data.dvc
file that can be tracked with git so i'm
showing you here a sample file and it
contains a hash that indexes the version
of the data set as well as its location
in cloud storage
so basically you can treat data as code
so it can be get versioned
even though the data set itself lives in
cloud storage
but in github your github repository you
will have a link to how that points to
your data in cloud storage
um and so we've created in cml an
approach to let you use dvc
in your github action so you can just
pass some credentials to your workflow
and then you can do things like dvc
pulled data dvc
repro so reproduce the pipeline if the
data set has changed and then you can
also use dvc to
push results from your ci run so if you
created a new model
on your ci run you can use dvc push to
push it into cloud storage
so pull data what it's doing is it's
going into the cloud pulling the csv
putting it on the runner and then dvc
push is going from the runner
to the cloud okay so some consequences
for continuous integration here
first changes in your data set can now
trigger a github action
even if the data set itself isn't part
of git
github actions can now push and pull
very large artifacts to and from cloud
storage
and data and model versions are linked
to every model training run
and because of you can start using
things like s3 storage
you know any you don't have you can have
these serverless
storage methods that means that you have
one less server
potentially in your workflow and that's
great
all right our third priority is that we
wanted to be able to let our ci system
allocate cloud resources to train
models and really quickly because this
one is is super cool but it's actually
we're changing the approach right now
and so i don't want to over provide
details on something that's going to
change
but um we've set up something right now
with docker machine
that basically means that anytime you
push you will deploy
cloud resources so you can actually
deploy an ec2 instance and it will turn
on and turn itself off after it's done
running your job
and we're still we're reworking this a
bit right now with terraform it is super
cool
um but it's not ready today but
basically with this
this approach you know in the way that
we have it right now we've done things
like
style transfer model on an ec2 instance
that has a gpu and a cool thing is
you don't have to worry about
remembering to turn off your gpu
or turning it on the ci system turns it
on and turns it off
okay so um to be clear there are many
solutions out there
and a lot of the things that i've showed
you are things that other teams have
done
we're just trying to standardize it and
make it into a cool open source project
that kind of puts
these resources together polishes it
um and try to popularize using ci
systems like github actions or gitlab ci
with machine learning um we really think
that there's a big opportunity there
and we're hoping that you know people as
they respond to this and try it out you
know
kind of help us develop it you know it's
an open source project and we love that
kind of feedback
so just to summarize what we've done
here
is uh we've created a couple approaches
to version data like code
and that our approach was dbc we wanted
to let our ci system allocate cloud
resources for training models
and we've been using this uh approach
that's kind of using docker machine in
particular to deploy cloud resources
from github actions so that you're not
limited anymore
by the compute that comes with the
github actions ci system
you can use any machine you'd like and
we can provide
feedback in the form of metric reports
and
we've written this family of functions
cml reports that will
we've written a family of functions that
will help you uh
write cml reports in your pull request
the priority here
is making data science and devops more
closely tied
in the ci process so
we really like cicd because of we think
that makes a lot of sense for machine
learning projects
it's a way of bringing together your
training data
your source code your modeling
experiments all
in one place and that gives everybody on
your team
shared access to every version of the
project including its history
and ongoing experiments and it provides
a standardized format for storing and
sharing
any kinds of files related to the
projects like data or models
whatever and so i think this is
it's it's cool because it's both a
cultural
and a technical shift and you know maybe
the way that devops has been impactful
for software development in general is
something that
we can also have in machine learning
plus automating things with really big
computers
is just a lot of fun all right
thank you for listening we are an open
source project and we would love it if
anybody is interested in what we're
doing has a cool use case
wants to maybe come on a youtube video
with us um try something out maybe we
can build something together
um and we hope that you'll join us so
you can follow us on social media for
project updates we're always down for
you know check out the repository and
our video series is ongoing
so uh you know subscribe follow along
and hopefully it's it'll be interesting
if you've liked this talk
all right thank you and i am happy to
take some questions